Thank you, very blessed to have crossed paths with you. Thank you. I've been closed by blood
work from yesterday. I'm very excited besides by 15-3. This is your CA-15-3, which is cancer
tuber marker. That's more specific to breast cancer. Going down a couple of weeks ago by CEA
went down. That's another tuber marker. So if you don't know what these things are, go to the post
on tuber markers. So you should search right there on tuber markers and see if you know what those
things are. So is there a tuber marker that you could use to monitor your cancer? So just like
this person, how could you monitor prostate cancer? Are there tuber markers that monitor prostate
cancer? Well, really not really, but PSA. PSA prostate specific antigen is a tuber marker for prostate
cancer. None of the other ones really are specific to prostate cancer. But you have PSA that you
could use. So my CEA went down this time also 12.95. Now that is a super, super significant drop.
So CEA is one of those with a really tight margin. Like 15-3 and 99 I think normal in 0-35 or something
like that. CEA is below 5 is normal. Below 3.5 if you're not a spoker is normal. So it's a very
tight margin for CEA. So it went from 12.95 that's a huge drop. That's huge. Question I have is
that alkaline phosphate went up a few points. Is this any concern? So this gets back to what I was
talking about way back on one of these questions. Is that the number one reason for some of the
liver markers in the metabolic panel. So this would alkaline phosphate is one of the markers that will
be tested in what's called a complete metabolic panel or a CMP. That is going to measure liver
markers and your cholesterol and cholesterol breakdown and your albumin and your other protein
markers, your STLT and your alkaline phosphatase. Alicine phosphatase will go up as I've stated
multiple times if you have bodeolytic attack on bodes. If you have metastasis to the bode and the
bodes be eaten away, which 95% of the time with boding metastasis of cancer,
it's a lytic metastasis where the bodes be eroded. Alicine phosphatase will rise but it will
typically spike. And you'll very kind of when they get a blood calcium level increase as well.
But the number one cause of it increase in alkaline phosphatase and a change in any of the other
liver markers is a toxicity of the liver or congestion of the liver but really toxicity of the liver.
And the number one by far cause of that is medications. So if you're taking any medication,
that's your culprit almost always. You're really when you're looking at alkaline phosphatase,
which goes up a few points, first of all, the range of alkaline phosphatase is pretty high. So if it
goes up a few points, it could mean nothing. And it probably does mean nothing. There's a plus
to minus probably 10 to 15 points on alkaline phosphatase with its normal blood test abnormalities
and reading abnormalities. But if it spiked way up, that would be a concern. But still your first
finger pointing would be to medications are taken off. Say, hey, I'm not taking any medications,
I haven't taken any medication, not even anything for a long time. Well, then you have to start
digging it into do you have any metastasis to bone. But you always point to, you're always at the
point to medication use. Even taking ibuprope people have a sensitivity to ibuprofen or Tylenol
and it can change their alkaline phosphatase really even taking a couple a day, even a couple a week
going to be affected by that. So I would suggest that it's that you don't have to worry about it. You
are taking medication, I would not even consider any that at all.